l'Union centriste et pour 4 minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président de la
Commission des rares sociales Madame et
Monsieur les rapporteurs généraux mes
chers collègues d'abord une remarque de
méthode la question je crois n'est pas
de faire le procès du gouvernement ou de
tel ou tel la question est que nous
n'avons plus le temps nous n'avons plus
les mains les moyens de rgversés car
nous n'avons plus les marges de manœuvre
vous avez compris monsieur Miski fallait
très vite recaler le discours et la
pratique vous avez commencé à recaler le
discours il nous faut et il vous faut
recaler la pratique pour autant la
question de savoir si ce que fait le
gouvernement est suffisant celle-ci elle
est pleinement légitime elle est même
salutaire car cette fois nous avons la
pression des taux et des marchés non pas
tant que les marchés délaissent notre
dette mais parce qu'il déteste que les
annonces qui sont faites maintenant
ne soit pas éventuellement vérifier
demain et il y a là-dessus quelques
points d'alarme ce débat sur le
programme de stabilité l'occasion de
rappeler l'attachement de notre groupe à
la maîtrise des comptes publics se capte
sur lequel le gouvernement se projette
aurait sans doute pu il aurait dû être
plus volontariste nous saluons la
volonté de rétablissement des finances
publiques annoncées dans ce programme en
revanche nous regrettons le manque de
précision quant au Modus opérandit la
dépense publique n'est pas mauvais en
soi
lorsqu'elle est utilisée à bon escient
et les crises récentes l'ont montré
l'argent magique n'existe pas et les
fonds employés devront être remboursés
la condition de notre souveraineté tient
en deux mots le sérieux budgétaire
force est de constater que dans la vie
au Comité des finances publiques cela a
été rappelé un certain nombre de points
d'alarmes existent des prévisions de
croissance pour 2023 optimistes ça a été
dit des prévisions de croissance
effective relevée
reposant sur une hausse de la
consommation des ménages des vêtements
supérieurs à celle enregistrée avant la
crise du covid tout cela pose quand même
quelques questions vous avez décidé de
fonder vos prévisions sur des hypothèses
avantageuses cela a été déjà rappelé
notamment une croissance potentielle de
1/35% jusqu'en 2027 alors même que les
scénarios de la Commission européenne
envisagé dans le cadre de la réforme de
la gouvernance européenne et des
violences publiques qui est beaucoup
moins favorable
l'incertitude autour de votre scénario
demeure donc élevé dans un contexte
international plus mouvement que jamais
où les incertitudes sont encore
nombreuses l'évolution des cours
internationaux des matières premières et
de l'énergie le niveau des taux
d'intérêt et la fragilité des marchés
financiers
constituent des aléas majeurs cela a été
dit par notre collègue Bernard delcro la
volonté de contenir les dépenses ne doit
pas conduire à des coûts de rabot
uniformes qui seraient à la fois injuste
inefficace la France doit se doter d'une
vraie stratégie d'évaluation des
hiérarchisation des dépenses à laquelle
le Parlement cela a été rappelé
notamment par le président de la
commission et leur partage général doit
être pleinement associé
d'un côté vous assurez tout mettre en
oeuvre vous maîtriser le budget de
l'autre les crédits des ministères
augmentent de 24 milliards et la charge
de la dette du toit les 60 milliards en
2023 une fois neutralisé la baisse des
dépenses exceptionnelles engagées en
réponse au crise la dépense publique est
bien prévue en hausse en volume il y a
un point qu'il faudra regarder de plus
près l'objectif annoncé dans ce
programme de stabilité de son
ressuscitue à une loi de programmation
qui fait actuellement défaut cette loi
de programmation des finances publiques
doit être adoptée au plus tôt ça sera
rassurant pour tout le monde elle
devrait afficher une trajectoire
crédible de réduction de la dette
publique reposant sur des hypothèses
macroéconomiques réalistes et une
stratégie claire et documentée ne
maîtrise de la dépense publique il n'en
reste pas moins bien sûr que les points
de satisfaction existent au lieu du
groupe innocentriste le gouvernement a
enfin pris la mesure de l'urgence pour
la France de se désendetter en réduisant
ses objectifs à l'horizon 2027 la
signature de notre pays sur les marchés
doit demeurer crédible cette crédibilité
n'est pas indé fectible l'abaissement
par l'agence Fitch d'un cran de la note
de la France est un premier signal
d'alerte afin de préserver notre
crédibilité nous devons intensifier nos
efforts et vite
la parole est à présent Monsieur Charles
Guenet
pour les républicains également pour 4
minutes